[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always I'm your driver
on this road
yes so my name is Caleb this is our
first ever live show hello everyone in
the YouTube chat hello everyone in the
room it's going on a deed show it's
going on hey there drew II it's good to
see you guys tonight I wanted to talk
about something a little interesting
I've gone over a lot of planning in my
last few lectures and you might have
been thinking this seems like a lot of
work do strong players actually go
through this whole rigmarole alright
let's look at the pawn structure figure
out a plan in every game
the answer is honestly not so much the
trick that strong players use is they
know the plans before the game even
starts they have their opening
repertoire prepared and they're you know
pretty much ready to figure out what
they're gonna do based on whatever
happens in the game barring some you
know extreme extreme circumstances so I
wanted to take a look first off of
course you can't talk about you know
openings and opening disasters without
looking at this game this is an example
of a former world champion not knowing
his opening so let's see what happens
here just to start it off and see e4 e5
Knight f3 Knight f6 so this is the
Petroff defense next up white takes the
pawn I'm very common black cleverly
plays d6 not falling for the first trap
of Knight takes e4 when of course Queen
e2 would be a pretty good game for black
or white I mean maybe black has to play
Queen e7 let's not go into this this
line is kind of nonsense d6 is the main
move Knight f3
I take c4 Knight c3 and now do you guys
know the move here there's a couple
options what would you play what do you
think for black no idea alright there's
a couple options here that the main move
that most people play is Knight takes c3
right this is the most common line also
available as an option for black though
is to retreat the knight
what is not an option is the move that
Anand played here which is Bishop f5 so
now white to move and win the game and
in one turn not buy checkmate but by
winning large amounts of material what
do you think tactics not so hard
any idea
9h forward to be interesting you're
trying to remove the defender right but
unfortunately he can take this night
also maybe has an intimate so like if
you tried the same idea with Knight d4
it can take here still but someone in
the YouTube chat hey there got it as
well as ascended lord and ruler of
something the right move is Queen to e2
so why do you think this moves corrects
yeah it just pins this Knight to the
king the only way for black to try to
save the piece would be to play d5 when
d3 would simply capture this Knight
almost for free in exchange for a pawn
so black is just losing after Queen e2
and Anand the former world champion of
chess resigned on move six so obviously
knowing your openings is somewhat
important at every level what I want to
talk about today isn't quite this much
surface level this is kind of just a
funny way to intro it and the way
knowing your opening kind of usually
appears in games is more like this next
example so this is a game I had quite a
while ago now against a local player
looky who's an up-and-coming kid he was
around I think you know 2000 when we
when we played this game and maybe a
little bit below 1950 or so and I wanted
to show what it looks like when you know
a 1900 player doesn't really know what
he's doing in his opening doesn't really
know the plans associated with his
openings so let's take a look and see
what happens
you for c6 Sorina caro-kann Luke is
playing white by the way I'm playing
black we see d4 d5 Knight c3 takes takes
so we're in the classical line of the of
the CARICOM Bishop f5 you know attacking
this knight in developing the bishop
Knight to g3 Bishop g6
h4 threatening of course h5 trying to
win the bishop so h6 Knight f3
Knight to d7 contesting this c5 squared
we see h5 Bishop age seven Bishop d3
takes takes c6 and these are all you
know the theoretical moves all these
moves are really are really theory and
so this is not what I mean when I say
you know knowing you're opening you can
know all these moves and still really
not understand the ideas behind your
opening that's what I want to focus on
today is understanding why these moves
are important why these moves are
correct Luke even continued playing
theory with Bishop f4 this move is fine
I played Bishop b4 a check which is also
the main move let me see the ship d2
Queen I five c3 so this force is the
bishop back and after c4 the queen is
forced to come back why do you think
white is forced to go on for this c3
move right away this is kind of a kind
of important that white has to play the
c3 c4 idea which allows black to kind of
move his pieces back into position
so if you were white you'd be kind of
you know you want to complete the
opening right so White's gotten his
pieces out he's controlling the center
the last step is to figure out what to
do with the King so what do you want to
do with the King here yeah castle which
way though yeah you want to Castle
queenside because you spend all this
time pushing this pawn actually with
tempo in the bishop so you want to
launch to launch an attack on this side
using these pawns so you would like to
put your king over here but the thing is
you can't right away because of takes
and Queen takes pawn so this is why
white actually has to play c3 here just
as it's kind of a side note so the
bishop comes back now we see c4 forcing
the Queen back as well so now there's no
you know tricks on the a2 square and
white can save the castle okay black
just continues development why it plays
even more theory with Knight to e4 I
take on e4 I think this is starting to
become like a sideline that's no longer
the main line Queen takes c4 and out of
six Queen e2 and now I want to ask you
what do you think the plans are for both
sides this one shouldn't be so hard in
general what are the plans
any ideas no answers so what happens
when you castle on opposite sides most
often is it like a boring positional
game or a you know tactical attacking
game when the Kings are on opposite
sides of the boards sounds positional
well it's actually going to be more of
an attacking game and the reason for
that is when Kings are on the same side
of the board it's not so easy to push
the pawns to attack right because you're
having to push pawns that are protecting
your own King right
for example if just for example as King
was over here let's just place some
moves it wouldn't be so easy to you know
start pushing these pawns up the board
right because you're weakening your own
King but with the king on the other side
of course it's quite common to do things
like you know push these pawns forward
to weaken my Kings side so yeah it'd be
attacking so yeah you have pawn storms
and attacks right so now we know you
know black wants to attack this King by
pushing these pawns somehow maybe with
straighter arrows and white would like
to you know attack my King he kind of
has a head start because this pawn is
all the way up here already but using
these pawns in this pawn is how he would
you know continue his attack where it
comes into play and knowing your opening
right you can kind of just look at the
position and realize okay both players
want to attack but knowing you're
opening means knowing the specifics
about it you know how does white
continue with this attack what are the
common ways that he can stop blacks
advances and push through with his own
advances and same thing for black how
can he try to stop White's advances and
push his own agenda kind of so with that
in mind what are some candidate moves
for black here how can he start you know
attacking this King while trying to slow
down White's pawn storms what are some
candidate moves you might play
just moves that look reasonable to you
yeah you might want to start pushing one
of these funds which pond do you think
would make the most sense here out of
these three
yeah I like the b-pawn too so one of the
most common pawn breaks in the caro-kann
probably the most common is this move c5
with the idea of attacking this weekend
d4 pawn right you know it's on a
half-open file it's easily attacked and
c5 you know kind of attacks it probably
first though black would want to get his
King out of the center to avoid any any
ideas of playing d5 when the Queen and
the King would be on the same open file
which is a little uncomfortable so C 5
is a good idea the move that you
suggested is the move I played in the
game which is actually b5 you know I had
seen other games in this opening I knew
a little bit about this opening line I
knew that b5 is sometimes an interesting
idea so do you think white wants to open
the area in front of his King or kind of
close the area in front of his King yeah
you know he would prefer to close it
right but something is wrong with white
trying to close this area down what do
you think might go wrong
so how first of all would you go about
trying to close close it up trying to
stop the pawns from exchanging and
opening files because if you're not
careful I'm probably just gonna take
this yeah so you can you can push to c5
right they don't go backwards
pawns don't move backwards right so
because they don't go backwards
every time they push forward they leave
squares behind that they can no longer
attack so what squares does it doesn't
leave behind
yeah the YouTube chat saying is d4 pawn
but even more importantly than the d4
pawn being left behind is another square
being left behind
yeah it doesn't always have to be a
piece it can also be week squares
yeah so it's it's on the D file it's
this d5 square right so this is actually
a great square for a night and now that
the c4 pawn is no longer there
you know this night would be kind of
unassailable and it could you know
control important squares probably
Knight to d5 right away isn't the best
move you know black can still try to put
some pressure here maybe push more maybe
get castled but leaving the square
behind is actually kind of devastating
to whites position so c5 isn't quite so
easy to play what are some other options
for for white do you think to you know
try and combat this this b5 break how
should he try to you know keep it under
control
no ideas so one thing he can do is just
you know kind of get his King off of
this file right that would be something
to try something else is you know he
could try to take and open the see file
or rather than the B file the best move
actually I think might actually just be
this king b1 idea this King b1 and then
you're not so worried about this anymore
cuz your Kings not on this file you know
you're preparing to open up and attack
this weakness that the black left behind
so probably black wouldn't even want to
take c4 here after king b1 maybe
something like Queen to b7
getting castles and putting more
pressure here as well as you know always
keeping this idea in the air instead my
opponent played a different move and I
want to get your guys's thoughts on the
move my opponent played what do you
think about g3 here this is what was
played in the game what are your first
impressions yeah so first impressions
first impressions
Yeah right it's kind of confusion right
what is g3 how is that relevant to the
position does that do anything important
and the answer is kind of no it doesn't
really solve any of Wight's problems it
doesn't make any new threats it it just
doesn't make any sense right so you know
wait if he knew the opening better he
probably would have known the most
common way for white to continue his
attack so what do you think or do you
guys know the most common way for white
to continue the attack which it doesn't
have to be a move immediately but it's
it's an idea later on down the line
how does white usually break up this
structure with the g7 and h6 pawns with
you know the pawn on h5 there's a very
common you know your sequence of moves
that happens
so let's say you know white does some
some move here like king b1 and let's
say I don't know black castles and we
find out eventually
okay 95 and Queen b7 does any move jump
out now now that we've played a couple
more moves gone a little bit further
down the line
No so when you're attacking and chess
especially on opposite sides like this
like I said the best thing to do is
usually push pawns so yeah the the
YouTube chat has some good ideas it's
you this is the idea that you want in in
these positions is you want to play g4
and g5 take on GC or h6 and open up the
position open up the King and usually
you find checkmate quickly after so it's
almost kind of incredible that my
opponent didn't remember this and if he
did remember this then to play this move
g3 right cuz you can play g4 in one move
right according to the rules of chess so
playing g3 first is really a huge waste
of time because it's doing nothing
except delaying your plan by an entire
tempo and so with that in mind you know
I had no qualms about castling here I
felt like castling should be fine since
he's wasting his time with this my plan
should you know go through faster yes so
he can't play g4 right away here right
cuz maybe I can take it maybe I can take
it I'm not sure I would because it's
kind of scary but maybe I can take it
especially since I haven't committed to
this yet but you know definitely some
move like 95 that was suggested or King
B 1 followed by 95 could you know
prepare this idea of g4 right preparing
the idea so that later on you can push
it through so after g3 I simply castled
knowing that you know his plan is gonna
come through slower now because he
wasted this time playing g3 and these
aren't things that I you know discovered
over the board like oh okay so maybe you
know white's plan is going to be to
attack me on the king's side somehow so
g3 maybe doesn't make sense these are
things i knew going into the game i knew
these things about my opening which is
why it's so important to study your
opening and by study I don't mean
memorize the theory memorize the lines
you want to study the middle games that
come out of your opening the middle game
positions around move 15 16 17 the
common you know positions that you get
the common ideas in your games there and
so you you'll know what to do when
you hit there so yeah that's enough
talking about g3 obviously it's not a
great move but a king b1 makes a lot of
sense stepping off this file and what do
you think blacks should play here he's a
few different options
any thoughts I'll stop using the word
idea since someone wants me to stop
saying it
and he thoughts any feelings about this
position for black alright so black has
a lot of options right he'd like to
continue the attack on the king the
question is just figuring out you know
what's the best way to do this so yes
some good moves are being suggested rook
D to b8
there's no ruck here but maybe this rook
you know putting a rook opposite the
king whether it be this rook or this
rook those moves both make sense this
rook a DD 8 makes sense in a different
way it's kind of not aimed at attacking
the King but attacking White's other
weakness which is the d4 pawn maybe I'd
like this rook on undie eight better if
if that's something I'm gonna play yeah
and suggested and chat is of course B
takes c4 this was the move that appealed
to me the most right because you get to
open up this file you get this square
for your knight and you know the
attacking possibilities become far
greater once this file is open so that's
what I went for in the game and I think
it's it's perfectly fine if five a4 is
another idea leaving this hanging for a
bit longer but I felt like the time was
right to take care now my opponent plays
Knight to e5 so he's finally getting
with the program kind of you know
advancing his knight on preparing to
maybe push at least so I thought so
again black has a few different options
here in the game I play it kind of a
weird-looking move which turned out to
be okay but maybe there are other ways
you can do it it's lept Jacob
good to see ya
so in the game I thought hey maybe I
definitely want to put a rook on this
open file alright all these ideas make
sense maybe you're on the D file maybe
pushing the this pawn down the board
maybe putting the circ all the way over
here and pushing this pawn down the
board
maybe my Queens better on b7
butter on a a5 but I can't leave this
pawn maybe I can push you know all of
these are our great ideas but first I
decided I want to misplace this Bishop
right so what is White's plan that we
decided we just talked about it what
does white want to do here yeah he wants
to push g4 g5 right
so I decided hey okay I'm this pawn is a
goner right this pawn is gonna get taken
maybe even the rook can come over and
put more pressure here and this bishops
well-placed right now on this diagonal
attacking g5 so I played this move c3
which yes someone suggested it in the
chat forcing this bishop to come off of
this diagonal where it supports White's
plan right this is a move aimed at
preventing White's plan for you know at
least a bit longer so now the bishop no
longer controls g5 which makes White's
plan harder to enact I continued with
Knight d5 just improving my pieces we
see Queen to c4 get played and what are
your thoughts on this move good or bad
good or bad so the idea is of course
Queen takes c6 someone's pointed out
that 2005 would be a bad move
I agree
yeah yeah you're absolutely right so you
know he thought okay maybe I'll just
attack this pun and something might
might happen out of it it's kind of weak
but you know of course you know white
should realize my plan is to attack the
King the plan is to attack the King so
the Queen belongs on this side of the
board where it can actually do something
to aid in the attack so while this move
makes some sense you know attacking a
weakness it actually just slows down
White's plan even further and now
White's gonna find it very hard to catch
up
I played rook a to b8 in the game this
kind of indirectly defends the the pawn
what happens if Queen takes yeah if he
takes my pawn
well there are some tactics that work
out in my favor if I trade Queens I
think so yeah hey there's got it so if
twin takes c6 Queen c6 Knight c6 and
then the final blow Knight takes c3
taking advantage of this pin this pawn
can't recapture cuz the king is hanging
so the King would have to move I can
take this you can take me I can take him
you can take me I have more bishops so
this line wouldn't be so great for white
the other option is Knight takes c6 and
what would I play here this one's not
well it is still pretty complicated but
this one also works out for me after
rook c8 so yeah the point is this night
is now pinned to the Queen you can't
retreat because I can take here on c4
twice you can try taking on e7 but I'll
just play Queen e7 Queen D 3 and this
Bishop still hangs because he's still
pinned so all in all wreck b8 defends my
pawn indirectly through tactical means
he plays King a1 trying to renew the
threat I simply play rook to c8
defending my pawn
Queen to d3 Bishop b4 what do you think
about this move on on my part here
what do you think
well there it's good whether it's bad
what do you think the idea is is it a
good idea
yes so obviously at its core it's
offering a trade of the bishops right
I'm offering to trade my bishop that was
on e7 for this bishop on c3 good move
because the bishop on c3 is better than
the bishop on e7 bad move because the
white bishop is bad these are the the
ideas and good because it gets the
pieces towards the king so yeah in the
game I was thinking okay what's my next
what's my next really break really big
breakthrough right oh yeah so all in all
people think it's good because it
removes a defender but let's look at the
specifics here so what do you think my
next big breakthrough is gonna be you
know it's something I can do quickly to
open up my last two major pieces that
are kind of stuck behind pawns still
yeah the c-5 move is is actually quite
strong say it if you were to try to take
you know simply Queen tix and you know
my my major pieces would definitely be
opened up right so uh this was my idea
right what's the obvious downside for
this for for black there's kind of an
obvious you know move that that's will
not move but an obvious piece that's
been improved by this
so the piece that's improves is actually
White's Bishop right it was looking at
this pawn stuck on d4 but now it's kind
of got a clear line of sight to my King
right so in the game I was thinking okay
so this is what I want to do to open my
pieces up but I'd like to get rid of
this Bishop first so this was the
thinking in the game it turns out
actually Bishop b4 is kind of just a bit
too slow you know the move is fine
principally but when you actually look
at the variations when you think through
it you know this Bishop really isn't
doing all that much even after the pawn
gets traded
and this just wastes a bit too much time
so even though principally it makes some
sense it is kind of you know missing the
urgency required here to open up the
pieces so white captured I captured and
now actually the move that white should
play is something like a3 the rook might
come back and now White's play on the
Kings side isn't really advancing fast
enough but he has some time now to bring
his pieces in and not to be won probably
probably sir cover to c1
maybe up to c2 he has some time to bring
his pieces in get some counter play on
this pawn before I get to play c5 and
kind of defend his king with his pieces
so this is something that white could
have could have considered is playing
like this and maybe my advantage is has
dwindled away with that in mind
probably c5 immediately it was better
however in the game we didn't see any of
this he instead played Queen to c2
I of course broke with c5 now that you
know I had traded off his Bishop Knight
to f3 I continued with Queen a5 just
bringing my pieces in we see g4 but
bye-bye now it's it's quite obviously
far too little far too late right
you know his plans gonna take many many
moves to annex and my plan I've already
opened the B file my pieces around the
AF file the C file is about to open
clearly you know in Black's play comes
faster the final blows just come after
okay for
a three and now I guess I'll let you
guys try and find the move here okay
let's go back for a second actually
so c5 you're saying I hung in exchange
I'm not sure I believe you guys
not sure I believe you guys blundered in
exchange and the line was c5 immediately
okay you're saying here I blended to
exchange uh let's see is this actually
true does this actually matter feels
like something should be wrong with this
land for white yeah probably Queen f2 is
okay yeah maybe not let's see maybe
you're right i blundered in exchange
okay I'll take I'll take this with the
bishop you guys caught me problem solved
but okay that would have been better so
Bishop before back here what do you guys
think the move is here
Black has a lot of good options probably
a lot of moose end up winning the game
but some moves you know better than
others maybe
yeah they're multiple ways to win night
before is a good idea
rook b8 is maybe not the greatest maybe
that one also works actually yes so in
the game night before would be good
maybe just like Queen C 3 here and maybe
tries to hold on somehow through some
magic not that I believe it the move I
played in the game was c4 and this is
actually the best move and why do you
think c4 is as good what makes it good
rook takes a three was actually also
winning it's it's a good one but this
one is more winning according to me
what's the idea with c4 what do you
think
so the main problem that's stopping me
from breaking through yet so see three
hits hard that's right the main problem
is stopping me from breaking through is
I'd like to take this pawn on a three
but of course you know the pawn is
defending it you know some players might
take it anyways and say I'm gonna win
your Kings way too weak they'd probably
be true or they'd probably be correct I
did it the simpler way which is just
taking care of this pawn before I take
care of this pawn white vainly attempted
to attack me with g5 I continued with
your p8 after King a2
unfortunately this falls for a tactic
with knight to be forecheck and the
Queen hangs had he played anything else
maybe G takes H there are some fun
tactics here any idea any ideas
mate in for for for black matin for ya
first mate
so yeah rook b3 it's a good idea it's
not forced mate though you have better
yeah hey there's got a rook takes a
three check B takes a three Queen takes
a three Queen a to only move and now put
the rook defends b2 of Queen c3 check
Queen B - and checkmate so that would
have been a good way for the game to end
of course instead of course my opponent
played King a2 which just gives up the
Queen
there are also checkmates here I think
like Knight c3 is some funny business
after you know pawn takes we have
checkmate and if Queen takes Queen takes
rook b3 is unstoppable mate this would
have been a good one for me to find but
I just took his Queen I just took his
Queen so that was that game and it's
pretty obvious why white lost right it
all started back with this move g3 this
move is just completely ante positional
it just doesn't make any sense of course
white wants to play g4 he wants to play
g5 he wants to attack the Kings side and
this move g3 just slows all of that down
there's just no way for him to continue
unless he you know even psychologically
admits okay g3 was wrong I need to play
G for now which took him quite some time
to to get a get a hold of so that it
mines any questions about this game
anything you didn't understand well
all right so with that all wrapped up
let's move on to a second game this is
another game of mine in this one I was
playing another local local kid beatin
up on the kids well actually this game
he beat up on me been Choquette this is
a game I had against him in the game we
started with d4 g6 the you know maybe
modern defense maybe Kings Indian
structures whatever you want to call it
we went with I went with c4 Bishop g7
Knight c3 c5 d5 now a funny line is
Bishop takes c3 B takes c3 but this is
almost losing for black but if y doesn't
know what he's doing it can be tricky
instead been played Knight of 6 plate
efore d6 Knight G to E - so I knew this
was kind of an offbeat line but I knew a
bit about it
so are you guys familiar with this line
do you know what the the ideas are kind
of so there's a very specific reason why
the night goes to e 2 rather than f3 and
that reason is it wants to go to g3 why
would the knight want to go to g3 here
what key squares take it does it control
yeah this f5 square is actually super
super pivotal and critical so that's the
idea is I'm going to move the knight to
g3
and control f5 and then more
specifically we'll see after it takes
takes Knight bt7 castles 95 what's the
best move for white here this one is
just begging to be played smoo should be
screaming at you please please play play
me play this move
okay Bishop g5 is a fine move it's not
screaming to be played though this move
95 is just daring you daring you to play
it has to do with our control over this
square as well so the YouTube chats got
it
any ideas yeah f4 you want to kick this
night out with tempo and then crash
through opening up the Kings side
opening up this rook so you can attack
you know the black King this is why we
put this night on g3 we controlled this
square so we can push this pawn forward
and activate our pieces and you know
been missing this was actually just a
fundamental misunderstanding of the line
he just didn't know that this is what
White was going to do or he thought okay
maybe it's not so scary for white you
know with all this in minds what's a far
better move for black here knowing that
what I want to do is play f4 and f5
what's a good way for black to try to
stop it there are a couple options
yeah hopefully if if Benzies this will
remember cuz you got a personal talking
to by yes to Sarah one I believe about
this opening line so we've all had the
benefit of yasser telling us the answer
which which does help because it can be
kind of tough for black if you don't
know this opening very well if you don't
know that F four or five is coming to
just kind of have that you know spidey
sense that something's about to go wrong
and you need to do something black
should resign not quite he actually has
some some interesting ways to fight back
so let's think of ways we can make f5
not good for white ways we can't do it
my favorite way of preventing moves is
always to make them illegal if the move
is illegal your opponents not gonna play
it ninety-nine percent of the time so
that's how you arrive at the move Knight
to e8 Smoove looks a little strange at
first but the idea after f4 any ideas
what was the purpose of night to e8 well
it frees the bishop but also frees one
other piece we don't often talk of
freeing pawns but the pawn on f7 has
been freed and can now jump to f5 and
the point of this move is make this it
makes this tonight look stupid makes
this Knight look stupid it stops this
pawn tonight can't go anywhere h1 is the
only legal move that doesn't hang this
Knight this rook is gonna be stunted for
a while and you know blacks gonna have a
good game and if white isn't careful
plays some nothing move like Bishop f3
black can actually take this Knight and
then this piece is also going to look
very very silly for a lot of moves it
has nowhere to go as all of these
squares are covered by the C pawn this F
pawns kind of in its own way so you know
white would run into some trouble if
he's not careful here so that's why
maybe white shouldn't play f4 after 98
you should sense that okay if I play off
for my palms gonna play at 5 I have to
you know kind of change change tactics
but of course you know Ben didn't know
the opening very well and so he just
played 95 running right into f4 and f5
and white is actually just completely
winning here already
it's move 12 and the game should have
almost been over but unfortunately I
managed to get into some trouble
Ben played some some good defense and
ended up winning this game which we can
take a look at since we embarrassed
Lukey for about half an hour I can take
some embarrassment as well so night back
to e5 I go ahead and pin this night
preparing to open it up and add another
attacker to f6 this meets h6
when I just decided to take this night
and after Bishop takes I play Knight to
e4 you know threatening to do some very
nasty things after takes on f6 so you
know if the bishop were to come back
maybe he runs into something like f6 now
this could be very uncomfortable for
black as the bishop gets pretty much
entombed so black fell or black felt the
need to play Bishop takes f5 which maybe
isn't the worst move but it does you
know tactically kind of loose after
Knight takes a 5g takes a 5 or a 6 f5
material is equal but of course my
pieces are all far better placed than
blacks pieces this is weak the dark
squares here weak the King as weak
should be an easy one Bishop g7 Queen c2
Knight to g6 King h1 all these moves are
fine Bishop to e5 rook to f1 just
putting more pressure here I adding more
pressure in the position Queen to e7 was
played Bishop h5 was played Brooke 88
was played and now many many moves win
what's the funny way to lose the game
for white
there's a funny way to lose here
I don't often ask you to find losing
moves but this one should be it's
something white wants to do but because
of blacks last move he has to be a
little bit careful can't do it right
away so in a perfect world we'd like to
pile up on this night right and then
take the night and then break through
and and kill the king so because of that
this move comes to mind Knight to f6
when after takes and takes you have
three attackers here the knight can't
move because you can take here but
unfortunately of course
what does Knight f6 run into yeah well
now black has a way to win after Knight
f6
yeah so Taco Bell at six in the in the
chat has found the idea well I can just
take this rook white can't take back
he gets checkmated so this wouldn't be
any good for white thankfully I noticed
this in in my game against Ben and the
best move here might just be something
like g3 creating left controlling these
key squares there's no good discoveries
with this Bishop on this night like
Bishop d4 now simply Knight f6 and you
can check me but you'll end up losing
well actually you land Blues in here if
you're not careful so of course
g3 would have ended the game black
really has no tricks after g3 and said I
played Queen to d2 and this meant Queen
to h4 smooth actually gave me quite a
lot of problems that I wasn't ready for
yeah but for some reason in my head I
was so prepared to meet any move with
Knight to f6 after after this Queen to
d2 move that I was just like okay Knight
of 6 is no problem after Queen h4 I just
take he plays some move I take care I
win the game this was my thinking in the
game of course what's wrong with this
thinking there's something pretty
obvious
something pretty obviously wrong yeah
something wrong with 906 here this one's
much less hard than than the last
question so yeah well night off 60s
check forces the bishop to come back but
then the problem is after work f6 this
is undefended the bishop is just
undefended so this is what actually
happened in the game here I actually
didn't realize I still have one last way
to save this game some way preventing
this mate in saving this night that was
so unnatural that nobody saw it then
didn't see it after the game I don't
think Yassir saw it but just cuz this
move looks absurd at first glance but it
makes sense only one way to stop it and
save lawyer material and that is of
course pawn to g4 which looks kind of
absurd but I would have still had the
advantage after g4 of course g3 would
have been better would have maintained
my advantage but instead this Queen DD
to move allowed this now since I didn't
see a g4 I had to go in for this piece
down business and I think I took on d6 I
don't especially recall but you know I
ended up losing this game pretty
convincingly which you know while it
hurts it goes to show you know don't
give up in your games because you know
this position really it's it's abysmal
for black and 99 times out of 100 flex
should lose this with equal players but
okay the point of this lecture it was to
show that you need to know your opening
and so the important part is this 95
move this really shows you don't know
the opening and so obviously you can't
know everything about every opening but
that should be your goal I guess is to
know most of the plans that can arise
out of your openings this is kind of a
sideline but it's not entirely uncommon
so it's definitely something Ben should
be aware of and all players who play
this line should be aware of
the point is you need to study your
openings not for Theoretical moves but
to recognize ideas if you can recognize
this F for idea you can recognize I have
to do something about it something needs
to be done and then you can arrive at
the conclusion 98 and f5 is a reasonable
way to stop it any questions about what
happened in this game and why why black
was just losing out of the opening and
also any questions in general about
anything we covered today
all right so then just a quick recap so
the point of today's lecture was to show
what happens when you don't understand
the ideas in your opening which is the
important part it's not the theory it's
the ideas in the opening and so if you
find yourself in a position or you don't
know the ideas that arose of the opening
you have to be very very very careful
cuz 95 is usually a natural move in
these kinds of structures but in this
case it kind of just loses the game
after f4 so you want to study your
openings not so much for theory theory
can help but you want to know these
ideas and you do have to be super super
[Music]
you know blacks should have lost this
game and white did lose this game you
know because of those things of course
also if your name is Vichy a nonce you
should recognize most six move traps and
try to avoid them
especially after not 94 but Queenie - I
think someone earlier mentioned you have
to show what happens after Queenie 7 of
course I don't remember right away
because that would be too easy
feels like the answers Knight d5 with
this bear at 1 c7 let's throw it on the
night with that in mind thank you
everyone for watching
it's been a pleasure doing the first
ever live streamed road to 2000 I hope
you guys you know enjoyed it had a good
time and I will see you next week
[Music]
you